every day every other day there's
something you get you're like I can't do
you make these movies it's like you go
away from the people you love you know
you can bring them to you on a set but
you're spending months away from your
loved ones and friends I mean for
everybody because I know if they do will
the truth is it presents an opportunity
for me need motivation watch a top 10 I
believe nation what's up at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from writing a play in
high school because one of his
classmates was shot and killed to
becoming an actor known for playing
Jackie Robinson in the movie 42 and
being the Black Panther he's Jagjit
Bozeman and here's my take on his top 10
Roza success joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite prove
them wrong what is the message to the
world with Black Panther I think the
message is that is that it that it works
to have you know black cast it works
that our stories can resonate not just
in this country but throughout the world
we've been on a tour showing the movie
we went to South Korea just before the
Olympics came and they're excited we
were like the Beatles in London so it's
that that that that idea that a black
movie can't travel that's that's been
said very often when when Studios talk
about funding movies they will make that
statement that you know don't sell
overseas yeah it's the exact opposite it
seems to be rule number two is don't
compromise your beliefs awesome and I
want to ask you a question that was
asked to Denzel once I really wanted to
get your response on whatever a role you
didn't take because it went against your
beliefs how much time do you have are
you asking to uh specific girl you want
to know what the role was cuz did this
happen is literally every day every day
every other day there's something you
get in you're like I can't the one that
sticks out of my mind and I cannot
remember the name of this movie because
he just didn't grab me and as far as me
doing it but I was gonna play the this
is after 42 I was gonna play it's
supposed to play the second lead so with
the sidekick right and the character
could not read he could not drive
and he couldn't swim in any and I talked
to the producers producers and directors
and I was like okay because sometimes
you get a script you'll see some things
in it and you're like well this could be
good this could be good but can you
change this and this and I was just like
okay let's just start with the fact that
there's no reason why he can't not read
like there's no reason why he shouldn't
be able to drive like he was and he was
supposed to be a criminal I was like
well how's he doing all these crimes if
you can't drive how does he get away his
mom come on I need you come pick me up
from the bench it's ridiculous I was
like what and then he couldn't swim it
was just adding insult to injury so it
to me is always though I always use that
as my like you know if a character that
has any of those times I say I tell my
friends it's one of those he can't he
can't read he can't drive he can't swim
roads you know
rule number three don't give up on your
dreams I studied on directing at Howard
so even though I was you know thinking
of theater and thinking of film I was
thinking about you know being behind the
camera being you know in the in the
audience
blocking scenes as opposed to being on
stage and is there a point where it got
more serious as an actor and kind of
give up the direction your day job I
haven't I haven't I haven't given it up
I still haven't given it up no I think I
think directing is in my future you know
recently sold a pitch to universal some
writings of them you know it's not it's
not like I've given that up it's just
that you know kind of want to ride right
now and I said get off of it
rule number four find your path I got my
friends together essentially to perform
some I read it's like my I guess my
journey at high school you know close
friend of my tongue at that time helped
me just sort of write this thing it was
fun it was like you know I don't think
we really knew what we were doing I
didn't know what it felt like you know
to be a director or to be an actor but
we had fun telling the story and the
audience loved it I felt like we had
good music you know music probably
probably helped to push the story along
in a way that I probably wouldn't do now
but it was just a fun a fun thing to do
with your friends and I think that was
the experience that that uh set me on
this path rule number five study the
grapes do you have to ask you about
Harrison Ford I mean seriously dude
you're working against Harrison Ford
what is that like
I mean it's it's like getting up for the
big game that's what it is you're you're
you Circle those scenes on the schedule
and say you know this is the big game
this is lakish Celtics you know this is
Bulls Detroit this is the Red Sox and
Yankees you know that's what it is so I
just looked at it as as you know this is
why you played a game what do you learn
from a man like him it's been around for
a while well you learn from his
experience you mean there's certain
things that you can ask him that are
that you that you don't learn when you
go to acting school you know you don't
learn those things in a classroom you
know and you might not you know you're
not gonna learn at other sets because
he's he's played the lead before that's
what he he's a leading man and in this
case I'm playing the lead it would be it
would be a foolish thing that I'd ask
him you know certain things about how to
do that
I asked them with small things at
moments and then other moments I just
watched them on set I watched how he his
rapport with the crew
I watched you know the way that he
understood how things moved around him
little tricks of the trade and you just
pick up up rule number six have a great
work ethic
it was really just a regiment everyday
just dance rehearsal five days a week
vocal rehearsals two or three times a
week and reading and watching footage
that I never could let a day pass
because we had such a limited amount of
time doing it and I have to credit that
work ethic credit 42 went for that
because it was a similar process if it
had not been for going through that
there was no way I could even wrap my
head around this process so that's
pretty much what it was it just just
diving in every day he was James Brown
from as soon as your feet hit the floor
this man had two months he was not a
trained dancer he had two months to
prepare for what you saw this is amazing
rule number seven work on challenging
stuff when you make these movies it's
like you go away from the people you
love you know you can bring them to you
on set but you're just spending months
away from your loved ones and friends
and you're spending like most of the
hours of your day concentrating on this
you know for months in advance of
shooting
and you're spending months promoting it
after it's over so you look at every
film like oh that's a whole year of my
life you know in some form of fashion so
to have something that you really feel
like it's gonna be interesting and cool
and a challenge like there's nothing you
want more than that
rule number eight root for others to win
we're in a time right now where I love
it I relish the fact that when I shot
Black Panther I'm shooting it with
Michael B Jordan and we can coexist
but there's this thing of if you're if
you're making movies and you're doing
well people start to say oh he's the
next Denzel he's dead right
making your success be based upon the
idea that there can only be one of you
and we as actors we talk about this we
talk about how debilitating that is how
negative it is how you know it's all so
frightening
you know I'm saying to a certain degree
because you feel like it divides and
conquers it makes us pitch you're
against it just us against each other
exactly so I root for yourself I root
for it for David and Michael with I root
for everybody because I know if they do
well the truth is it presents an
opportunity for me rule number nine care
you know they're there to two little
kids in and Taylor who recently passed
from cancer and throughout our filming I
was communicating with them knowing that
they were both terminal and and what
they said to me is in their parents said
they just they're trying to hold on till
this movie comes
and I to a certain degree you hear them
say that and you're like like wow that's
like I gotta get up and I gotta get up
and go to the gym I gotta get if we go
to work you know I got a lot of these
labs I gotta work on this accident you
know seeing how devoted all of my
classmates are and knowing that that
that that that will be something
meaningful to them but it's to a certain
degree it's a humbling experience
because you like this can mean that much
to them you know but seeing how the
world has taken this on see how the
movement is how it's taking on a life of
its own I realized that they anticipated
something great and I think back now to
a kid and just you know waiting for
Christmas to come waiting for my
birthday to come I'm waiting for a toy
that was going to that I was going to
get a chance to experience or a
videogame I did live a life waiting for
those moments and so will put me back in
the mind of being a kid just just to
experience those two little boys
anticipation of this movie and when I
found out that they
take your time with it yeah this is it
me the bye and rule number 10 the last
rule before some very special bonus
clips is sing the reality of this show
you know instant song you'll never sing
a James Brown song I just accepted it
it's just weird way you know it's ok
don't have to I don't have to know you
have to sit come on
your cha cha this guy has taken on
everything he's fearless your Black
Panther yes you couldn't shy away from a
little bit of something mmm let me see
wait let me see what would I say mm-hmm
when mouths hands
Clapton Churchill Sunday morning when
miles has played the tambourine so well
grandmas Hayes used to issue out a
warning she say Chad don't you run so
fast might fall on a piece of glass
maybe snakes there in their grass
grandmas hey
I've got some very special bonus
Chadwick Clips around being different
being the best and learning how to say
no that I think you're really gonna
enjoy but before that my question the
day is have you seen the Black Panther
and did you like it or not I saw it I
loved it I want to know what you think
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
assimilating all this James Brown your
performance on step when you're finally
on set shooting your experience is much
like other films when I when I read the
script I didn't expect it to be written
the way it's written I didn't expect the
direct address I didn't expect you know
the nonlinear storytelling you know I
didn't I didn't expect it to be as you
know as different as hip as it is in a
certain way and I felt like that she
usually would I'm looking for is
something that it has something
different to it so I want to be a part
of that that idea of Wakanda popped up
in certain ways in my travels and in my
readings for you it was kismet yes
exactly
a row that's a departure for Bozeman
rose to fame playing historical figures
Jackie Robinson in 42 James Browning you
don't know I certainly wouldn't be here
if it were not for those men that I
portray seeing me play those roles
actually got me this role Marvel
executives were so taken with Bozeman
they'd be fooled the move they almost
never did Chadwick didn't have to
audition Chadwick didn't we were in a
development meeting for Captain America
Civil War forgive me though is the
brother that good yes he is that good I
asked him about that they like together
let them say that I stand on you know on
the shoulders of the men that I play
when I'm walking through the lab and I'm
feeling myself because I'm key with you
know my sister there's a little bit of
James Brown when I'm holding court
there's a little bit of Thurgood
Marshall what's the best piece of advice
you ever got learn when to say no and I
want to say now what's the worst piece
of advice Yolo you only live once the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]